Mi nombre es Romanova Valentina Iosifovna
Nací en la guerra de Ucrania el 22 de junio de 41
cumplió años bajo bombardeos en
Babi Yar mató a mis parientes
24, 22 de febrero, me reencuentro en
Kyiv bajo bombardeos y bombardeos
Putin, reúne a tus tropas y lárgate de aquí.
queremos ucrania en paz
[música]
en
no tengo palabras
imprime cuatro generaciones de mi familia aquí
estudió
reprimido y de alguna manera dejarlo mentir y
El checo no va a ninguna parte.
voluntad
todos ustedes [ __ ] mezquindad odian
mi ultimo aliento queda en mi
de todos modos y
ganar eso es un monstruo
auto
acaba de atropellar el coche
humano
[música]
[aplausos]
caer
terminado perfectamente
[música]
Tal vez
ya te refieres a mi
6980 entonces lee como 40 si vas a nacer
Ucrania es mi periferia de las mentes de las personas allí y
no, bueno, estoy hablando de daño y ahora
mono mano en john
póngase en fila
[música]
aparato de la casa
adiestradores de perros piña
[música]
la gente bloquea la carretera con un camión de leche
en la iglesia
como gritar que caminos
Tranquilo, no seamos más geniales que lo que son los vigilantes
de estar asustado
sigue mi ejemplo y desde yo bastante
jubilado y tipo de provincia me lleva en
día lluvioso visto en cómo aguantar
ejército por lo tanto completamos los batils cosacos
la poliarquía sol ellos se las arreglan para ganarlo en
susurro ayuda mantuvo comprar un cepillo
aguijón y ayudar al ejército se abalanzó ruidosamente
una ráfaga de r.a.
[música]
apurado por saltar tan lejos
un montón de lil kate &
fuerza
[música]
te pido que ruegues tu vida
instalar revocar hisar detener
esta guerra
sobrevivió a Stalin y
sobrevivir a putin
barco ruso
estos estan jodidos